john mccarthy
this gentleman could indeed be the
software developer
look at that beard uh developer of
arguably the first
functional programming language in the
world lisp this is an example of it over
the side over here
don't ask me what that does i don't know
lisp apparently it's very cool i
understand it's still used today
very nice but anyway
so what is functional programming not
well the point of the last few slides
was that it's nothing new
it's been around for absolutely ages
most of those gentlemen
did their work in the 1950s and 1960s
and the origins of functional
programming date back to the late 1800s
i have indeed dug out some of those
papers but again
not a mathematician so they caused my
eyes to sort of steam over
and some sort of strange liquid to start
pouring out my ears it was
hard going because i don't understand it
but
anyway it's nothing new uh
it's not like the latest trendy
framework coming out of
react or angular or whatever
it's not a language it's a paradigm
and if you want a metaphor for a
paradigm if you want to think of
a musical instrument as being a
programming language
then the genre of music you play is the
paradigm
you can take your guitar and you may
play pop music you may play rock music
you may play country in western if you
have no soul
but the point is that you may play many
styles of music with your same
instrument similarly with a programming
language you may program
in many styles of programming
and it is not imperative or object
orientated
those being the other two um dominant
paradigms
uh most of the people that i've come
across who've struggled with the
concepts of functional programming
tend to be those like a lot of us here i
would imagine
who've been doing object orientated for
upwards of 10 years
and find it a little harder to adjust to
a slightly
well new way of working but most of the
people i've
come across who picked it up almost
instantly tended to be students straight
out of university
in fact when i was in minnesota giving
this talk uh i got chatting with the
interns at lunch
and some of those said that actually
this is what they're teaching
in universities now as the way of
programming
so to a degree if we're not getting into
functional we might be
left behind in five to ten years who
knows
it's not the solution to all of your
problems but i would argue is the
solution to
many of them hopefully some or all of
you will agree by the end of this
and it's not difficult it's not
difficult at all it is
a little bit of a conceptual leap for
anyone that's not already gotten into it
but it's not actually hard so what is it
what actually
characterizes a functional language a
functional
code so important concept is
immutability
and this is fairly common functional
programming we've got a funky
word for something that's not terribly
hard to explain
uh immutability is just that once a
variable has been set you may not change
its value
again no matter what you can't really do
this in c
sharp but i kind of proceed as if this
was the case
f sharp absolutely but we'll get a whole
other topic
higher order functions again funky word
something that we've been probably doing
for years this is functions passed
around
as a variable either as a parameter to a
function
or as a return value out of a function
but that's all it is
if you've been doing link there you go
it emphasizes functions not statements
what's a statement
a statement is an if a while for
all of those guys there are other ways
of doing this stuff in functional
programming
referential transparency who actually
just means that um a function
shouldn't rely on anything other than
its own parameters
seems simple but it has some marvelous
consequences
so the whole idea is that the function
should become
completely predictable it shouldn't rely
on any external state or any
anything else anywhere except for the
things coming in
so it means that given the same
parameters you will
always get the same answer out of that
function no matter what
no matter what state the rest of the
system is in no matter the life of the
universe no matter anything i
suppose you could turn the computer off
but other than that pretty much
these same inputs give the same output
it's often called a pure function
uh recursion i'm assuming we're all good
with recursion
anyone who's not speak now
recognition i'll kind of get onto that
in a bit this is basically
uh switch statements with knobs on
stateless so referring back to uh
reference transparency the
the pure functions there is no state in
functional programming as such there's
no
it's not like the object-orientated
world where you have this object which
contains the state we modify the state
we track the state
this concept doesn't exactly exist in
functional programming again
other ways of doing it monadz ah
so according to douglas crockford the
curse of the moan ad is
that once you gain the ability to
understand it you lose the ability to
explain it
so i shout and it's not
difficult as hopefully we'll agree
shortly
where is it so where can you find it of
course there are the pure functional
languages haskell erlang there are
others i know there's a whole load out
there
i've heard great things i've never
personally used them
i've heard air lang has been having a
lot of success recently i believe rabbit
mq is airline
so i've heard they're great if you want
to
do them go for it have fun enjoy
but not something i've touched on myself
probably should at some point
i've also got some friends that swear by
haskell so i think i'm going to copy the
book around here somewhere
javascript would you believe javascript
supports functional
to a crazy extent that c sharp doesn't i
have another talk on that subject if
anyone's
ever demented enough to want to hear it
and see which is
why we're here so when is it
it's not that it can't do other things
but this is generally speaking where
functional
programming is happiest where it's most
uh effective
so data processing again thinking back
to your your pure functions
then just this data comes in this data
goes out functional does that stuff
really really well so if you've got like
a rules engine or something like that
something that just chunks data from one
form to another functional does that
perfectly i will probably do it better
than nearly any other paradigm
concurrent systems so this is
where you want to speed up a whole load
of processes running in parallel doing
roughly the same task
functional supports that really well
because no state
because most of the problems that you
run into with uh async
is things like uh resource contention uh
changes in shared state between threads
stuff like that generally speaking
doesn't happen with functional
high criticality systems because a
functional program tends to be more
stable than the alternatives it tends to
be more robust
um i think airline's claim is something
like
once their program is actually compiled
and executed it's nearly impossible to
kill
and i don't doubt that i don't doubt
that at all
and serverless referring back to the
concurrent systems if you're interested
in something like
as your functions or anything of that
ilk
then again functional programming is
probably one of the things that's going
to
support that
so when is it not oh sorry mentioned aws
lambdas thank you
yes same exact thing except that's in
the aws world
so absolutely aws lambdas i'm pretty
sure there's other
instances of that serverless technology
thumbs up to you as well okay when is it
not
so it can do these things but this is
where you have to make your compromises
so functional likes predictability it
like stability uh
but these things are inherently not so
ui
dealing with files dealing with uh input
and output devices
external interactions with other systems
third-party systems
and io you know there is nothing more
impure
than a human being let's face it so
this is where compromises have to be
made and the various
functional or non-functional languages
are made their own efforts to
deal with this problem but the image i
keep in my head is that of a shadow
shadow has two parts the dark center
that's the umbra
and then the gray fuzzy bit around the
outside that's the penumbra
and what i like to think of is that we
want to keep the umbra the dark bit the
pure functional bit as
big as possible and then push the
non-functional fuzzy bits on the outside
as far back as we can
to increase the amount of functional
that we have and decrease everything
else
so at least we can maximize the amount
of awesome code that we end up with in
our system
so why is it why on earth should we be
interested
certainly these are my answers it's
concise
and that is not a small thing to me you
go from about
this much code often to something a
little like this
which is marvelous because i am a very
lazy developer i don't like typing a lot
of code
i like to just get on with my job as
fast as possible and functional is
brilliant for that
it's readable in part because of the uh
concision
it's much easier to read what we've done
plus it tends to lay things out in a
nice logical fashion uh i'll get on to
examples in a bit
extremely testable i know for a lot of
people the testability is one of the
huge draws of this
uh thinking back again to the concept of
your your pure functions
uh it means that all the functions that
you write tend to be extremely testable
because
they're predictable they always give the
same results for the same input
so throwing together unit tests is a
doddle
enables concurrency touched on that
robust i've touched on that
and fun i think it's fun uh it's an
awful lot more fun than typing out long
calendars i now tend to think of the
alternatives as being so
moving on to the how of it which is
going to take up the majority of the
rest of this talk
so this is a bit of non-functional code
this is the sort of thing that we've
well certainly people like myself who've
been in this game a long time
have tended to write a lot over the
years uh incidentally anyone who can
guess what the uh titles over here in
the corner are automatic is
automatically one of my friends
um but i will give you like five seconds
to work out what on earth this is doing
and i bet it would take an awful lot
longer some of those folks have been
doing this longer than i have will
probably get there quicker because we've
done it so many flipping times
but my point is that
we've got an awful lot of code here to
do something that's relatively simple
the logic is split in many places um
it might take a bit of staring to work
out precisely what it is doing
or could rewrite it like this
incidentally for anyone who's playing
along with home those are the episode
titles of the very first season
of doctor who from 1963 uh doctor who
for those not aware is the greatest
tv series in the entire world and i will
fight anyone that tells says otherwise
right but my point is
this is functional programming now if
anyone is about to think at this point
well that's just a bit of link yeah it's
totally a bit of link
that's link is functional programming
and that's a deliberate choice on the
part of microsoft
i was here well i say here i was over
here in from
the real here ndc oslo about two years
ago
and there was a talk there from the head
developer of
um c sharp uh he keynoted
and i asked what's the intention with
the functional content in c sharp
and his answer was what are you doing in
my room
but after i had been tied up and beaten
and the police had been called
then the explanation was that the
intention is that my c-sharp is a hybrid
language
it is absolutely going to support
functional programming going forward
and every iteration of c sharp going on
is going to contain
more functional content than the one
before it uh the f
sharp guys and the c sharp guys are
mutually uh benefiting from this
increased
functional content so
it is absolutely the way that they're
they're moving the language so
here if we look at these these of course
are
shorthands for functions these are
functions being passed
as a parameter that's functional
programming that's how it works
and that's all all of this does so if
you're comfortable with
link then hopefully there's not going to
be anything in the rest of the talk that
will boggle your mind too much
uh we've got a couple of questions
okay stern says he's interested in game
programming unity is his
tool of choice they've been lately
focusing on a new paradigm d-o-t-s
data orientated tech stack i have never
heard of this
i think i might have to hit google once
i get back
but he says what i've said this is
functional that's cool
might be don't know that might have to
be something i look up later
um and someone has asked if i could
see if how one should think differently
when you're testing functional code
versus o
good question i'm not exactly going to
touch on that but maybe bring that up
again at the end and i'll see if i can
put together some thoughts okay so
uh you could even go a step further on
my comment on my previous uh
slide and you could start throwing in
some things like this if you wanted
so i'm just storing some funks i'm
guessing that everyone is okay
with funks if you're not it's going to
be a tough lecture for you sorry
but you can store your functions as
variables here and then you could
quickly and easily define each piece
separately of your program
so a split on comma here which literally
does that and nothing else
a parse data which just does that and
nothing else and then you can stuff this
all together
into something that reads like this
so and then another function is just
placing it all together so now
that reads almost like natural language
i could probably show this
to my manager and now they might not be
able to modify this or
entirely understand it but roughly
speaking you can understand
what this does even if you're not all
that technical
because it's not it's fundamentally all
that different what you're seeing here
and it's got lovely descriptive words so
this for me is a huge benefit
of functional you tend to end up with
stuff that
looks like what you're trying to do
whereas your old
for loop with a list view for me
it's probably more what's happening
behind the scenes once the compiler's
messed with it
but i'm not interested in that i don't
really care how it works
i want to know what it does
so this is a big old block of code
which might be familiar to some people
in the uk these are the validation rules
for what's called a nina
now i used to do work for hmrc that is
the tax
revenue people for the uk so i am very
familiar with the
national insurance number uh
don't even get me started on what those
things are but there's a whole long
list of rules which define whether a
nino and national insurance number is
valid it's down to
which characters go in which space
within the number
which are letters which are numbers
which letters you may have
there's a whole load of uh rules
and in this case i am
the structure of this code is that i am
checking each rule
if a rule fails as in that rule isn't
true then i'm returning false early
and then it's kind of missing off the
back of the screen at the moment that's
rubbish um otherwise if i go to the end
of all these rules
then i return true awesome or i could
write something like this
so you don't have to actually separate
out everything like this like i have but
i just kind of like to do that sort of
thing
because it makes it an awful lot easier
to uh
to read what's going on but all i've
done is
i have separated out each rule into
um a line here so it must have length of
nine
there we go a nice simple definition of
a string
having a definition of a length of nine
you could
you could blend this all together i
don't really mind uh let's start with an
alphanumeric
and so on you could you could see it's
pretty clear what we're doing here
but i have stuck all of these functions
into an array
which is a subtly powerful thing to do
because
you start finding all sorts of fun ways
to play with it once you've done that
because you can apply link to the array
of functions
and here we've got an all so what does
all do all is a link feature
what all does is go through each item
in the array run this and if
every single one returns true that's
good will return the whole thing true
if at any point any of these individual
things return
false then we just terminate the whole
process
early and return false so
all i'm doing inside the all lambda
expression is
feeding it the nino spring uh with any
spaces replay
uh someone's just asked for a link to
the slides i will absolutely put a link
at the end to the slides
no worries uh i think there's plenty if
you have a dig around on twitter you'll
find a million copies of um
of my slides around there too but don't
worry i will make sure that everyone
gets the slider wants them
so my point is that this all
has um completely replicated
all of the structure of code on the
previous slide which
was about this jupiter long only
i'm doing it in this little statement
here my return
early my final return true at the end
all of that
easy peasy and if you wanted to get rid
of all these guys you could you could
just merge all these into here
jobs are good um
so yeah why make things hard
why write all those lines of code when
you just don't have to
and in fact i could do something like
this if i wanted to now i'm assuming
that
everyone is good with extension methods
because once again if you're not good
with extension methods gonna be a tough
hour for you so i like extension methods
i think they get a bad rap there are
ways of using them and there are ways
definitely i'm not using them
but i keep them small simple and generic
and that's what i'm doing here
so i've created a validate extension
method
which attaches to a t i've called it t
input because i like
clarity and but that's still a t
so attaching to a t means it attaches to
everything in the whole of c sharp with
no exceptions
and i'm taking a params i love params
params is awesome if you don't use
params you should
and so what i'm saying is give me
a whole list of predicates that is
validation for rules uh taking t as the
input
and bool is the output to tell me
whether it's right or not
and then you could just do this so i'll
do my replace just
once i'll call validate and then i'll
feed it each rule so once again
we've compacted down the code
a little bit smaller we've got a
reusable set
of um validate function
features here which we can apply all
over the place so
just made for me at least c-sharp a
little bit friendlier and easy to use
if you really wanted to and i'm not
going to dwell too much on this slide
but you could go and break down each of
those rules into
little sub-bits of rules so you've got
all these sorts of reusable pieces like
you could have a generic has lengths off
and you could feed a nine into that if
you wanted
is all yeah there's all sorts there's
all sorts of ways you could
break this down but in principle what
we're doing is turning functions
into lego bricks and we're breaking them
as small as possible and allowing us to
stuff them all together to build up our
little lego castle or whatever we
want to make and then you'd end up with
something like this
does that suit you better than the
previous guy i don't know it's certainly
very generic and very readable and if
you wanted to maintain this thing
it would be very simple to throw in an
extra rule if you wanted to take a rule
out again just delete a line drops a
gooden
it's clear what the rules do if someone
comes back and says the rules aren't
right you could just literally show them
this code
and say what's wrong in this description
and they could they the non-technical
person could probably tell you oh
hang about it's actually the character
between two and seven not two and six
but bang jobs are good right
moving on to the uh the sort of
programming exercise we may have seen
before i'm going with bank accounts so
i've got my
standard bank account with a balance and
an interest rate
i'll imagine that we inherit off that
with a super duper bank account she's
got
ballot the bonus interest rate and the
the dodgy bank account which has got a
brown paper bag stuffed with money
probably left in a car park now
i usually make some sort of comment
about
um a certain politician in the news
whoever happens to be in the news at the
time but these days
take a pic i give up
right now this is the sort of functional
way
of handling uh applying the interest now
obviously this is a grossly simplified
version of applying interest but
this is just out of the box c sharp
eight i believe it is
where we are casing on the type
we're actually casing on which type it
is based on
this ba is referenced previously as
being the
the sub to the uh the master the parent
class which is the standard bank account
uh but if you case it based on it's a
dodgy bank account here
then it will actually be automatically
wrapped converted into a dodgy bank
account here if it is in fact one
and then we can run our rule here
referencing this local variable
um without any worrying about checking
edge types or anything like that we've
done an awful lot of
if type of equals blah blah all sorted
compressed into this and again here if
it's the super duper and
i could even put a when in here to say
if it has this particular balance so
this again is out of the box c sharp in
fact i think this may
be slightly out of date now but um my
point is that
this is functional programming again
this is pattern recognition this is
kind of what it looks like uh oh someone
says if this doesn't turn into a c sharp
eight switch i would just pointed sorry
stan you're gonna have to be
disappointed i think this slide is that
you'd be slightly out of date
do look up city sharp eight switch
patterns because they're even more
powerful than this stuff
but this is all that pattern recognition
is so um
yeah do do look into this stuff
and i do believe that their intention is
to take inspiration from pure functional
languages and add
further uh content to this type as we go
along
so another bit of fun with arrays of
functions
you know now this is
a super stupidly simplified version of
applying tax to salary
it never really works like this in the
real world but it is loosely based
on the uk tax system and what i have
is a series of rules and
based on what your salary is i decide
which rule to apply
now this would probably involve an awful
lot of if statements if i had to write
this out longhand
but here what i've got is um
an array of tuples each of which
contains
a funct two functions i'm again assuming
that everyone is good with tuples
but on the left hand side we've got our
conditioned
a condition selector and on the right
hand side
we've got the actual rule to apply
uh so that's just a tuple where we've
got decimal ball and decimal decibel
here
and down here i'm doing a bit of link to
say
do dot first and dot first is saying
get me the first where uh the condition
that is the left-hand one
when you feed it the salary returns true
so what that will mean is it will go
through these one at a time
until it finds one that returns true so
if you have
a salary less than 11 850
then it'll select this one out or if
you've got a whopping great salary over
150 000 because wouldn't that be a
lovely thing
then it would select this one out but
it's selecting out at this point
the whole row so then what you have to
do is call the calculator i've called it
calculated which is
the second half of the tuple and then
feed salary
into that that took me an awfully long
time to explain
but actually once you've got that
concept in your head
understanding this looking at it is not
all that complicated
we've got a set of rules we've got the
transformation to apply
and it's not all that complicated to
write
excuse me so
moving on to some excuse me some other
functional structures
so let's imagine for a mode that we've
got um
two different sources of data we've got
a hypothetical database operation that
returns
some data and we've got one that returns
a null for example
uh a load of it says very cool
tacticality to thank you very much
so i don't know what these could
represent anything maybe one of them's
an xml maybe one of them's
a a web api lookup doesn't really matter
i don't really care
use some imagination so i am saying that
i want to
feed in let's say my name and then i
i want to get out some data and this
structure
here will allow me to try
each one in turn and then actually
return out the one that works
so normally i would have to do things
like null checking
and stuff like that and this is a way of
getting around all of that sort of
annoying
code bump that you have to put up with
so i'm saying here are two functions
i don't know which one's going to work
try each one in turn
and then bring me back whichever one
works into here
and i don't really care except that i
will now assume that it works
and how does this actually work it's
kind of like this
alt is as good a name as any for this
i've heard now something you may hear me
saying quite a bit over the next uh
next few slides is a lot of these things
have got many names
i've gone with one name that seemed like
a good name to me
feel free to call it what you wish but
i've heard this called alt i believe the
proper name for this sort of structure
is a functor
i think so this is an extension method
i'm taking a t
input again that's everything and then
i'm saying
here's some funcs i've got f1 and f2 and
i've also created another structure down
here called if default do
now this takes uh this
this takes the func which is the else
and it takes an input
so what it does it says this by the way
is the slightly terrifying
generic way of checking against null
because
once you go into generics of course not
everything is
null by default if it's an integer or a
boolean or whatever
they default to different things so this
is checking against zero if it's an
int and so on so forth so i'm saying
that
if this thing is null then take the else
function and run it with the input
otherwise just return whatever it was
the thing that wasn't null
shove it back again so that means that i
will now say
function one run function one pass it
the input if default do so
if function one executes and we get out
a null value or
equivalent then execute function two
passing in this
if this came out with a value do not
execute function two
and whatever the result of this guy was
return it
again took me a long time to explain it
pretty simple in practice
this is another similar structure this
is a fork
i could make some sort of rude joke here
but i shan't i'm better than that
um and hypothetically this
is an input and i have chosen a
deliberately stupidly simple example
i don't know why you never want to do
this in the real world but again i don't
want to get bogged down
in the logic of what i'm trying to
accomplish i'm just trying to illustrate
a technique so hypothetically i want to
go
and count how many a's how many b's and
how many c's are in this input string
and i want those all to be done
separately so
i am going to do dot fork so a fork is
kind of like you know
it's got prongs and a thing linking them
together so each prong of the fork
is um is a different function which is
doing a different operation
on the source input the same input each
one of these prongs
is acting on the same input and doing a
different thing
and then this function here sticks them
all together
so because i'm using a params and stuff
i've had to put the sticker together
thing
at the beginning but that's just how we
have to do it uh you could do all sorts
of
alternatives if you wished and what i'm
doing
is just summing them i mean maybe you
wouldn't really sum them you could do
all sorts of other complicated
operations
it doesn't really matter but you get the
idea single input
split it into multiple functions which
run separately back into a final
output at the end
and how you do it is something like this
uh map incidentally is one of the
greatest little tools in c-sharp that
you never knew that you missed
and all it does is attach to everything
and then
take a function which converts whatever
this is
to the next thing just means that you
can basically do link
but instead of selecting and applying to
each item in the array
you're selecting base and transforming
the whole object
i just find it means you can compact a
code an awful lot tighter
so i'm saying that the prongs are a
params taking function of input to
output
and we're selecting them based on
whatever the transformation function is
and then mapping
with a join function so oh sorry passing
in the parameter sorry
and then using the join function to
stick them all together again
now you could go as complicated as like
this stuff i have written fork functions
which
had multiple stages because i wanted to
convert from type to type to type
you could do all that sort of thing but
this is the simplest possible
explanation version of
of this structure
so i mentioned currying briefly but i'm
good
right currying korean uh someone just
asked how async can await with playing
with his forking it would play
very well indeed uh i haven't actually
written an async version of it
but i would imagine that you'd probably
just put in a weight uh
inside the extension method and have
that wait for each of the prongs to
um to complete and then return the
result at the end
and you'd make the whole thing async i
mentioned right back at the beginning
but uh things like async are very well
supported by functional programming
so it plays very very well with that
sort of thing
carrying so this is a hypothetical
normal function this is an add a plus b
wow that's simple
give it 10 give it 20 we get back at 30.
but let's imagine that this was a
curried add function and i only give it
a single parameter
what do i get out of this if i've only
given it two per one parameter when it
takes
two the answer
is and by the way this is a rule of
thumb with functional programming
if there is a question the answer is
functions mostly works
and yes the answer is you get out
nothing because my there we go we get a
function
so we give it one parameter out of the
two
what we get back is a function which
represents
the base function but where one of the
parameters is now filled in
so by giving it a 10 it has now become
an add 10 function
if i give it a 20 it would now be an add
20 function and so on and we could store
that locally
it means that you can take a great big
long function with loads of parameters
and
apply them piece by piece and reuse each
piece of it multiple times if you wish
without writing a whole load of similar
but not quite the same code
to uh accomplish various different means
so question on everybody's lips i am
sure is can you do this in c
sharp bit
sorter this is probably the most
effective way i've
found to do it um that is
what you notice here is that there are
two arrows
so this is an arrow function returning
another arrow
function so this does indeed do roughly
what you saw
on the other page um
if you pass a 10 in to this what you
will get is
this arrow function back where this x
has now been filled in with a 10
and so long as wherever you've stored
the call to this
is still in scope this whole thing
remains in scope as well so
excuse me do watch out if you're writing
this sort of thing the order of
operations
is important so that of course has to be
a y minus x
so you absolutely can that's the easy
way
does this have its uses it does it
can kind of prettify
some of the code that you might write
elsewhere uh
to maya to add in more sort of
descriptive language
i have seen other ways of doing this in
c sharp with extension methods
but i can recommend a book which talks
about that sort of thing it looks
pretty ugly behind the scenes but it
does work so
it is possible but it requires an awful
lot of
malforming of c-sharp to make it happen
so this is a plaza
back to our doctor who uh in fact anyone
to talk about some of this stuff in a
minute so
this is excuse me a funk which is
parsing these doctor who stories
what i'm doing is taking a b c and d so
a is i believe the whole string
b is which character do i split on
in bc is which of these three fields do
i actually wish to
extract and d is the source data itself
i think
yes d is the actual source data so the
spring itself
so excuse me
how can i actually partially apply this
stuff
do something like this i have created an
extension method called apply
so first off i am calling the funk
and i'm calling dot apply how apply
works i'll get to in a minute i'll show
you
but i am passing in two parameters out
of the four
this means that this parse here has now
become
a parser which given any amount of
string any strings at all will
split on new line then split on comma to
create an array of arrays a
two-dimensional array
and i can reuse this one as many times
as i want if i've got a whole load of um
other stuff to you know to be processed
elsewhere i can just reuse this same
exact thing
and i don't have to write separate
functions to do it this handles all of
it for me
then i'm going to write a function here
which is taking the pars
and then just passing in one function
with the apply
and it's saying 0 0 being the 0th
position
out of the array which is the story
codes
and then if you pass in this string into
here
these new lines are just here for the
sake of making this readable uh
then you get back abcd and so on
basically
piece by piece i've created separate
reusable functions
which i have partially applied to and i
get back
a list of the story codes here i've
referenced pars again
so without having to write another
parser or write another block of parsing
code
this time i've partially applied but
giving it one so without writing any of
the code i've now got
a function which will blast through this
break it into lines break it into fields
select out the warmth position which is
the story title and then return it
so it means that you can write one
function which does everything
and then use something like apply to
apply in the parameters piece by piece
and then reuse each of those pieces
wherever you wish
without writing an awful lot of vaguely
duplicated code
what apply looks like is something like
this now i did say it was ugly and it is
uh yeah i'm not gonna dwell an awful lot
on this but basically you're saying
given a pr um a funk with this many
parameters i'm going to return back a
funk with
fewer parameters and i'm going to stitch
in the uh the appropriate bits myself
when i return it
it means that if you wanted to do this
method and by all means do
it it means that for every combination
of how many parameters
in to how many parameters out you're
going to have to write one of these
extension methods
so potentially an awful lot of writing i
don't think it's necessarily a useless
endeavor it can mean that your code can
become an awful lot nicer it's just that
i would probably shove this
in a code file somewhere way at the back
of the code base and try and pretend it
doesn't exist
but why not so last
phase of a functional flow this is a
typical functional flow
we start off with a string or whatever
it doesn't really matter we start off
with one thing
and then typically the first instance
you can you split it up into many things
functional programming works in many
ways more like tsql or symbol aware
we're applying list based operations
to a whole load of data in one go so
we'll do some where's we'll do some
selects
we're converting types we're doing all
sorts of stuff and then the final method
is aggregate so we're aggregating
many things down to one thing
and the traditional method of course is
to have uh
something like a list which we're
appending to or here this is a
um a string builder same principle
loop through append loop through append
i'll just do a string.join which is the
really nice
simple way of doing it and this is more
the functional way of of thinking
this is a whole load of story data again
for doctor who
because doctor who is the best and i've
got here things like the ratings the
number of episodes in that story because
back in the old days doctor who was
always multiple episodes for each story
and the number of missing episodes
because tragedy tragedy
there are missing episodes of doctor who
there are i believe 97 missing episodes
if anyone's got them hand them over i
want them
but there we go that's the way it is so
what if i wanted to
aggregate a whole load of data out of
this
i feel like i'm almost telling you
something that's simple here but i have
been astonished by how many people don't
know about this
but obviously you've got your extremely
simple basic aggregators we've got
some passing and a function to tell it
what to sum
similarly i've got average passing a
function to tell it what to average
and then we've got our more complicated
aggregator and again
i'm astonished how many people don't
know about this but it is
i think one of the coolest things in c
sharp next to
dictionaries dictionaries are actually
my favorite thing at c sharp i love
dictionaries so what is this aggregate
doing
well first we give it a seed value now
in my case i'm giving it a tuple
and not a notch so two integers with
zero and zero as
the um the starting values and then i am
passing in a function with two
parameters
the accumulator and the current value
call these as you wish this is what i
tend to go with
the current value is just like your x in
a normal link expression in a select or
whatever
that's the current value coming out
that's each item in the array one after
the other
and the accumulator is the running total
so
far so the first time this operates on
the first item in the array it's zero of
zero
this function then tells the accumulate
the next accumulator what the value
should be
so we take in the accumulator item one
and then add to it the current number of
missing episodes
and again on item two and then add in
the number of episodes so
piece by piece what we're doing is
blasting through this and creating a
running total of
how many episodes in the story versus
how many missing episodes
by the way around there and then we can
do a percentage at the end this is
ridiculously simple stuff and you might
possibly
not entirely want to do something so
simple with aggregation but
again i'm keeping this simple just to
demonstrate the technique
you could imagine passing this all sorts
of complex objects and then doing
operations on them
to reduce them down into an answer at
the end
and i would probably not let this get
too complicated without breaking it off
into sub functions anyway
but you get the idea so this is
incredibly
powerful it means that you don't have to
generally speaking you don't have to do
that
for each with a list or anything like
that again you could probably do
something like this
uh i've used this a great deal certainly
in the
in my day job and in things like if
anyone's familiar with the advent of
code
i do love the advent of code and i use
this sort of thing an awful lot in that
so uh i don't really have time for this
this is a bit of head-meltingly
complicated code and i saved this for
user groups when i have to talk for
longer so
if anyone's interested in seeing a bit
of insanely complicated code talk to me
afterwards
right uh last piece i believe and then
we can all rest because i believe we're
running out of time
right fahrenheit to celsius i used to
work for an american company
and one of the things we often used to
talk about because i am british
is the weather uh it is not a cliche we
really do talk about the weather a lot
uh mostly because it's so flipping uh
unpredictable over here
so they would say to me and i'm not
doing the accent i can't do it it's
embarrassing
uh how bad my accent is that is right
they would say to me things like it's
100 degrees outside and i think whoa
100 degrees outside that sounds like you
should be dead
but no that's in fahrenheit working on
celsius i think something like 32 which
is yeah it's quite nice
right what is the process for converting
fahrenheit
into celsius well it's deduct 32
multiplied by 5 divided by 9.
course it is wow so
then i'm doing some rounding because i
don't want a great big long amazing
uh super detailed decimal and
then i'm formatting it here nicely into
something with a degree centigrade on
the end
so what's a nicer way of rendering all
of this lot
this is a structure called an identity
let's not dwell too much on why it's
called that it's got lots of names
or too much about the detail but what
you have to bear in mind here is this is
an identity of t
so this is of tybena thing doesn't
really matter what and inside here
is a value it's a t it's a dirty and
it's called value so it's
a thing in a box that's the only thing
we need to worry about
think in a box we got a box inside of
the thing the thing is our value
easy i got a couple of little bits of
syntactic sugar down here
some implicit operators it's just
because i'm far too
lazy to do all that typing and
i have got because i'm being a
functional programmer i'm not letting
you change it
this does not have a setter the only way
that you can set it
is in the uh constructor
so a couple of extension methods i'm
creating one called two identity
and this is attaching to everything and
all it does is
whatever the thing that you just called
to identity on
it takes that value whatever it was and
stuffs it in the box so you've got the
thing in the box
and then bind this is where the magic
happens bind is not all that different
to the map function i referenced earlier
so this again attaches to uh all
identities so once you're in identity
this bind will now attach
and all i want from you is a function
which takes the old one
and turns it into the new one so that's
my multiply nine my divide whatever
that's the thing but
the process and then whatever that
function is i'm going to run it
and then whatever it comes out of it
i'll stuff it inside another identity so
take your function take my thing out of
the box run it into your function
pull out the new thing stuff into a new
box give it your back
and now my fahrenheit to celsius looks
like this
it's a nice orderly chain of operations
so i have also used i did mention that
they have their uses
my um my curried adds and subtracts and
all that sort of thing from earlier i've
used them here
now if you wanted to you could do
something like x arrow
x minus 32 but i don't know i kind of
like to make my
code very descriptive so each bind
is running the function opacity so these
are functions these are functions these
are exactly the same as arrow functions
i'm just writing it in a descriptive way
so
this bind says take whatever the input
is run this function which is a subtract
32 function
take that whatever it is if i started
with 100 then what does that make it oh
god my mental rights would take it's so
bad
68 i think and then stuff that inside
another identity
which can then be called with another
bind and we do another operation
and because uh i've made it a t input to
t output
um you can convert type to type as you
go through this chain
otherwise we might have to add an awful
lot of sort of little local variables
with different
uh with the different values in as we go
along
and you'd end up with all these little
local variables that you'd have to just
chuck away
someone says more sound effects
right the name for this kind of
structure
is a monad i said i would not explain
what they were
i lied this is a monad this is just
about the simplest stupidest monad that
you can imagine
but it is in fact a monad so what is a
monad
someone just said this is the equivalent
of piping in a command prompt absolutely
exactly the same
concept if you understand piping in the
command prompt basically you understand
moan ads to a degree
but that's all the monad is it's like a
relay race
you've got each person passing the baton
to the next
except that each person's not just
literally passing unchanged they're
doing an operation they're multiplying
they're dividing their
i don't know chunking it up whatever it
was you want to do and then passing the
new version
to the next person and then so on that's
what a monad is
it's not that hard is it i think that's
quite easy
and this is something else that you
might possibly want to do
if like me you grew up in the 90s and
you think you are cool
you might want to replace various
letters from your name with letters to
make it leap because leetspeak's still
cool isn't it isn't it cool
it's cool yeah still cool so
i've created another moan ad called
maybe
i'll get onto it in a minute but uh same
principle though
i'm binding um with all my various
functions
my first bind is take the id here which
is
for the sake of argument uh an integer
probably doesn't want to be an integer
in real life
but i'm that's going away to a
hypothetical database and coming back
with the value
and then we're like taking some uh
details first name last name and age
and then i'm replacing a's with fours
with threes ice with ones
there's probably a function here that
will take your baseball cap put it
backwards too just to be even more cool
but the problem is that get person two
here
might not necessarily actually return a
value
person id12 might not exist this might
come back as null
so if that would happen well what
happens in this bind when this operates
if x here is null
someone says missing t to seven yes
you're right i need a t
to seven darn it right but if this comes
back as null
then um this is null this is null
this explodes in flames
so that's not good so says how will we
know if we're leak
yay you can't you're just exploded pull
up you
right but how can monads rescue us from
this scenario
it can with the baby so this is the
maybe
so we've got an ab now we've got this
here is the equivalent of our identity
before
thing in a box in a box
and this is called baby it's an abstract
though i do not ever want you to
actually
instantiate a maybe not direct and i've
got an abstract
t value here another implicit operator
because i'm just lazy
and i have implemented it out into two
subclasses now i've heard these called
all sorts of things
i've heard maybe also called option i've
heard
so just also called something nothing's
pretty consistently called nothing
though
fine but anyway you may find these under
different names it's all the same
concept
but this means this just is an instance
of the maybe
where the operation worked and this is
an instance of it
where it didn't work the just here is
exactly the same as an identity it's
just thing in a box
carry on like normal but nothing on the
other hand here
this overrides it and so if you can see
for me my video is blocking that but
that's default
so i'm overriding t value and i'm saying
that is just the default that it's zero
if it's an int it's null if it's
anything else you get the idea
and those are the two possible states
that my monad can exist in
something or nothing just or nothing
whatever call them what you watch
and this is how i actually implement it
so i've still got my two maybe which is
exactly the same as my two identity
that's just take this thing turn it into
a thing in a box
easy but i've got a more complicated
maybe now
the parameters the same a thunk that
takes old type to new type
and the maybe which is the this and i'm
switching on it
i'm switching on this the maybe and
first i'm casing that
i am saying that i'm casing that is
adjust that is it does contain a value
currently
when and this is again the the default
check
i'm saying that it's not null so this
case is assuming
that the previous operation worked and
that we got um
a not null value out of it if that's
true
we'll go into a try catch statement and
we'll actually run the function if it
explodes
then we'll return a nothing
if it succeeds we'll return out
something but
it might be that it contained null in
which case the next time that we execute
this we'll check it
and if it's null or if it's already in
nothing
then we just do no operations at all and
go straight
to nothing so the best explanation i
ever heard of this
was from the website f sharp for fun and
profit
marvellous website not just ref sharp
developers there's some very nice
conceptual articles it's scott flashing
i believe his name is
and he described this as something like
railway orientated architecture now this
is a metaphor i love a lot and i'd
recommend that website
but imagine that you've got uh imagine
you've got
uh two sets of train lines you've got
the the something line
and the nothing line and every function
is a set of points
along the line and at every set of
points we check is this still working is
this still working
if at any point it doesn't work for
anyone in any way
we switch we switch from the happy line
the just line the something line
over to the nothing line and we just
coast all the way to the end
so that means any functions after that
point are not executed
it packs in an awful lot of
functionality but doesn't actually
require
much thought once you understand it and
gives you um
an awful lot more uh i want to just put
the f sharp fun and profit
link in the um uh oh
uh in the chat there i'll probably try
and share those in my notes afterwards
it's a very good website but yeah so the
point is that things like
try catching is now baked into the data
into the structure of our code checking
against null is now baked into the
structure i code
those are two things that normally we'd
have to do time after time after time in
order to make sure that our code stays
robust
but now it's just here we don't need to
anymore
turn it into a maybe call bind the null
check
and the the try catch are just
fundamentally
provided for you and in theory you
shouldn't ever be having
any more exceptions ever again
which is nice
uh how are we doing oh that's time okay
i'll just blast through this really
quickly because we're about out of time
but this is a slightly more complicated
version again this is either and roughly
the same idea except we've got a left
and a right uh i've heard these again
called all sorts of things
uh your your right is your happy path
your right hand of justice your left
your left hand of evil left hand of
darkness that's it didn't work
but the diff it's roughly the same
concept as the maybe except in both
cases i'm catching the value i'm
still maintaining oh no don't turn that
into a default except
with the left hand path i am also
capturing the exception
so i am saying that if an exception
occurred
we'll shift from the right hand path of
true justice
to the left-hand path of evil we'll grab
that exception whatever it was
we'll glide down to the end and then you
will have the exception captured
and it's all just there at the end for
you in a single value
that's what it looks like it's roughly
the same i can think of all sorts of
ways to make this a little bit more
interesting and
capture some more useful data but i'm
just keeping things simple
and um i would probably
uh have this returned as the return
value of a function as in i'd probably
have a function return and either or a
maybe or whatever
to signal the fact that there is some
uncertainty as to whether this will work
and then i probably use something like
your uh your switch statements to
to switch on type to determine like okay
now i know what to do if it worked or if
it didn't
oops someone has asked in the past
whether there are any libraries out
there that already implement a lot of
these structures there are
languagex is the only one i'm aware of
at the mo
i think there are might well be others i
had a little play around with language
x seems pretty good some of my examples
reworked into languagex
they call uh bind map that's the same
basic concept
and uh they have a match at the end so
it's like you have to go into them
the map world of doing the binds and
then you call out of that world by
you're defining a match which collapses
based on which of these functions are
called
into a real value all seems pretty good
i've had
a bit of fun playing around with that i
personally
like to just implement it myself might
be a little bit extra work for me
but i like to understand what's going on
and since functional is
relatively new to me although i've been
doing for a few years now um
i'd like to actually get my hands dirty
and implement it myself to make sure i
understand
what's happening
further reading and i promise you this
is the last slide
you can all breathe right functional
programming in c sharp by
enrico buenano this is one of my
favorite programming books of all time
it's certainly one of the best that i've
read in years uh some of the examples
that i've given were based on some of
the material in this book i love this
book
i have been occasionally badgering him
on twitter to try and respond to me but
he never has
curse you when we go by that oh but it's
a marvelous book
and if anything that you've seen here
seemed interesting or fun to you
i thoroughly recommend this book if
nothing else i loved it
uh functional she sharper vishnu angoro
apologies to him if i'm mispronouncing
his name
it's pretty good i like the buenano book
better but this one's nice as well
there was a youtube video which kind of
started me down this path uh well
i would say youtube video this was a
talk at ndc oslo many years ago
which i was actually present at kathleen
dallard this is a nice one as well
and uh um she catches on some ideas i
haven't like having say
one global try catch for the whole
application
that's lots of other nice ideas i
recommend this one as another starting
point
there's a couple of pluralsight courses
they're not bad you could go on to f
sharp fun and profit scott vlashin
absolutely i like the website uh if you
really want to go hardcore go all the
way
stick pick up a book like learn your
haskell for great good
i have a friend or so that swears on
this thing
go for it now
any questions
silence oh someone's put a review for
that book functional programming can
make your head explode this book
stitches it back together i
like that that's quite nice oh fantastic
thank you
ryan oh and
yes malika has just prompted me that uh
i didn't ask about unit testing okay my
brief thinks thoughts about unit testing
um because functional programming when
it's done properly
relies entirely on pure functions that
being
a function which may not rely on
anything except for its own parameters
you could basically do a whole load of
unit testing without actually
doing any uh mocking potentially you
just
pass it in some values which you just
feed it directly and then get back out
the answer
the whole idea of passing in mocks to go
and get data which are executed by the
function
that would be anathema to the functional
process
so the more that you write your
functions
based on this idea this idea of purity
the easier it'll be to just unit test
everything
so try and stick more to that try and
think
more in terms of splitting down your
functions into smaller pieces because
again functional programming tends to
look better when you've got
small pieces rather than a lot of the
stuff i've seen in the object orientated
world where you tend to
um like functions are
thousands of lines long and i've seen
some of those guys and
have gigantic messes of uh ifs and ifs
and ifs that look like family trees
because in functional programming you're
sort of writing these nice little flows
you tend not to get into that mess and
you tend to end up with
nice clean small easy to understand
functions that are easy to test because
they've got often a single um a single
purpose
so just by following this paradigm it
tends to push you
down a direction of easier testing
uh someone has oh what we got
oh someone said what about the
complicated part well i hope i hope
everyone
feels that this is not too complicated
the uh the stuff that i've been saying i
i don't think it is uh of course you
know yeah it's it's quite easy to go
down some strange rabbit holes sometimes
with this stuff as always but
uh oh someone asked about the bit i
skipped over sorry yeah
maybe not while we're on the recording
um but if anyone's interested
grab me and i'll i'll give a quick talk
about that it's a sort of head-meltingly
nasty bit of code i wrote that does some
strange things but
yeah it's a sort of example put it all
together is there a git repo with these
examples
uh git repo there might be but certainly
the slides
yes i will put up a link to the slides
uh i've got it on dropbox
i'll uh i'll probably pop it on this
conference room
also i am on twitter mad simon j
uh grab me there you'll probably find
copies of my slides around and i shall
probably put the link there too
so uh so what else do i mix and match
pyrogramming paradigms in the same
project solution
if it's c-sharp yeah probably i try to
maximize the amount of functional that i
do
but c sharp b c sharp sometimes you have
to make compromises and it's just
inevitable but to be honest
by and large you could write an entire
application in
exclusively in functional in c sharp if
you wished
does mean writing a load of extension
methods and jumping through some hoops
and i'm not sure if it's always going to
be optimal
c sharp's not necessarily optimized for
functional in the same
the way that f sharp is but you could do
it
you absolutely could um in fact as a
challenge to yourself try
doing something like i have which is
take on the advent of code
and write the entire thing in arrow
functions
only in pure arrow functions it can be
done and if nothing else gets your head
around functional programming that will
uh okay uh it's time to so okay uh if
i've got time for the last one uh
someone asked about big o complexity
er in c sharp probably it might well be
pushing up the big o a little bit
but that's not necessarily my end goal
my end goal is not necessarily only
towards uh efficiency and speed my goal
is
maintain ability and ease of ease of
reading ease of maintenance so
those are more important to me than
anything else so sorry anyway
uh grab me on slack uh or any way you
would like and i will answer as many
questions as anyone has
but i think we need to uh to wrap up now
oh someone says that's fantastic twice
very kind of you thank you michael
okay thank you very much folks